okay so part like a big reason why
that i had so few games to pick up to
pick from right is because
when i really get into game i really get
into a game
i i ring out as much content as i can
out of that game every side quest every
little piece of dialogue i play it to
death so i can get
everything like with let's say so with
metal gear
right so there would be times where you
know
are you familiar with the codec calls
until they would like call you up and be
like yeah snake
yeah yeah exactly so so one one of the
big criticisms of metal gear when you
know i was playing it and you know when
it was like really really big was
people hated the cut scenes how long the
cut scenes were people hated
the fact that you had to go through all
these codec calls
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] man i'm like
i'm like holy [ __ ] there's an hour cut
scene be right back getting the popcorn
i
this is the most epic
gears gameplay the one with like psycho
mantis is that the one
it was that was the first one that was a
photo yeah i thought the first one was
like the
top down like nes one
i don't know i mean that's metal gear
that's metal gear not metal gear
yeah because like every time i watch
because i've watched tons of videos
about metal gear and every time i watch
it i'm like [ __ ] i wish i like got this
when i was a kid because
it looks badass it was [ __ ] badass
and but the thing the thing is like okay
so there's metal gear and there's tails
as well tails has
this feature right i mean you play the
tails game yeah how did you think about
the skits feature
or skits what was that
okay oh wait is this what you talk with
the character and the fire emblem thing
what wait what
where you interact with characters no am
i crazy
kind of so in intel's games they have
this thing called
skits right where you'll be walking
around and then you press like the
select button when they give you a
prompt right
and it would just be characters talking
to each other
oh yeah i'd never i'd always do it
so like i was probably the one [ __ ]
person
who just hit every skit button like i i
don't care what
what time i'm in what like at which
point of the story
i would just like i i literally played
tales and i literally like
there are some skits that are only that
that only happen at certain areas of the
map which are like
some areas of the map you literally have
to walk on the other side of the map and
there was no like quick
well this is a big boulder huh yeah it
sure is it literally doesn't mean
[ __ ] yeah and it literally doesn't mean
[ __ ] i [ __ ] love that feature i don't
know man
i like because here's the if i love the
characters and i love the world i'm i'm
getting every kind of like
i'm getting kind of interacting with
every interaction
same thing with mass effect when people
talk about how much they love mass
effect
they talk about oh you know the
character writing and you know the
well not so much the gameplay anymore
but like the world and
the characters that uh of mass effect
um i was probably i like i remember
there's there was one mass effect
gameplay session i had where i literally
wasted an hour or two
because in mass effects they have this
it's not a codec function but like a
database function where
they literally have a database of like
every
like the history and law of like every
alien every world that you go to
so i literally i literally spent an hour
or two of mass effect
going through the entire database and
just
and just reading the whole law of mass
effect i'd rather not
i'd rather not you know
and i [ __ ] loved it i i absolutely
loved it um
i can't even shake my head because i
used to do that exact
same thing doesn't want to play a game
read a book or some [ __ ] the [ __ ]
i did i did that recently actually when
i played xenoblade 2 for the first time
and there's this like there's this part
where like every monster you encounter
has like a full page about like
how it lives and [ __ ] yeah i read
through all of them i'm like oh okay so
like the zafaros only lives in the
swamps
like to to me that's that's what really
makes a video game
like it's especially because if if i'm
like really into a video game
i'm gonna find out everything i can
about that video game and that's what
like but the thing there's a difference
right because i like
when it's just fed to me in video games
like people
have talked about you know the law of
dark souls and everything like that
and people have like figured stuff out
through the subtle hints that you get
through playing the game
i'm just like just tell me it just just
yeah just just give me exposition this
is the one time where i actually want
exposition
you say that all i think about is the
[ __ ] um the silent hill person
who's like um no no sorry so there's
like on on silent hill forums
there's like where they discuss like
what the game's about and stuff yeah it
was like a really big
thing and a big like like controversial
like drama because
one of the main admins who'd had like
some of the most posts on it was like
convinced
that the main character was circumcised
and that was the reason for his like
trauma
and that he was like gay or something
and then he was gay because of it or
something like that
and so this whole like dude like wang
made like a 20 minute video about it
and it's like this whole thing where it
was like a massive deal on the forum so
they're discussing
you know is and then the guy was like
you know he was
like a crusade being like no one should
be circumcised it causes trauma and
stuff like that
and it turns like a whole thing and i'm
just like this is what people do this in
my mind i'm like that's
people who read story that's what they
do they go on forums talk about why the
main character is gay and his
circumcision was trauma
yeah yeah what's wrong with these people
play a [ __ ] video game why why are
you typing about it
i'm not even surprised by that because
yeah i i that's so like when you when
i'm relieved and you like it being
like the story being told to you yeah
you're like i want to figure it out is
my character actually like gay or
something
let me see circumstance i need to know i
need to figure it out
they've left hideo kojima left me hints
that metal gear
solid snake is circumcised
which is funny like i'm more than happy
to watch anime where i'm just like oh
what's the subtle
what's the subject what is the author
trying to say but with gaming i'm just
like nah no patience
just just give me well because you're
already focused on like actually playing
the game yeah yeah yeah
where it's like no no i don't need to
like i don't want to like sit here and
[ __ ]
guess what the story is what i'm trying
to do this convoluted input right yeah
and there's there's also another thing
that uh also
like it's gonna be it's gonna sound
super weird but sometimes
i hate choice in video games i just want
a linear game which is which is funny
that massive
literally the [ __ ] mass effect
literally mass effect persona 5
but like yeah yeah mass effect and
persona 5 which are the two
like let's say the two uh most choice
heavy games yeah
two of the most choice every games and
the two exceptions the two exceptions to
that rule but
i have i have this thing i i don't know
if i'm the only person who has like
gaming fomo
where i'm given a choice and and i know
that like by making this choice i'm
gonna miss out on a certain
piece of content oh yeah i hate that
i hate that so much right because that
means that means
in the back of my mind i'm just like but
what if i picked the other choice
and and well that's literally the reason
why i replayed persona 5 four times
because i was like well there's four
choices
yeah yeah and i want to see all of them
so i'm gonna play it four times to get
all the choices
i i think it's unfortunate that i i like
swore off jrpgs after playing blue
dragon
not really which i mean i think i've
mentioned this before yeah
yeah the one that was like i think the
main selling point that comments were
saying is that it was uh the art was
made by the dragon ball uh guy oh yeah
toriyama yeah yeah and like
i never encountered this before in a
video game and this is what really
pissed me off
because at this point i was an
achievement hunter guy so i would always
go in like 100
i would get all all the achievements no
matter what yeah this is the first time
i encountered the thing where i'm like
okay so this story is two hours long or
some dumb [ __ ] like that it's
ridiculously long
yeah and i did it and then i'm like all
right how did i get these last few
achievements and it'd be like
this achievement is on the forum would
say this like this achievement is only
unlockable by doing this one option in
this one mission yeah
you can never get this achieved yeah
yeah like what
what
and that's so [ __ ] up that they would
do that like what kind of sick [ __ ] does
that because they're like i don't want
anyone to be able to get this
achievement make them play the whole
[ __ ] like 200 hour game again
[ __ ] [ __ ] there's no need to do
that why would you do that as a game
designer
i don't know forget you it's to get you
to replay the game right
yeah i mean ie [ __ ] [ __ ]
everything i mean
like the the reason i hate it is because
it takes it takes enough energy for me
to finish a game once
so i'm thinking [ __ ] if i need to replay
this game i'm just not going to see this
contest
right yeah yeah dude if you want to see
the shitty turn based combat you should
play blue dragon man
every time you [ __ ] start a battle
the [ __ ] the mute the main song
starts playing yeah it's a guy [ __ ]
singing it sounds like the pokemon intro
and then it takes like 20 seconds of
animations where they all like summon
their things
which is like it's like 20 seconds long
before you can even start the [ __ ]
turn
don't tempt me
i also hate in jrpgs that like they give
you these characters and like what if
you hate the characters that you have to
use
like in pokemon at least i can swap out
you know bulbasaur but like most jrpgs
like it's you know like especially with
that turn based ones right it's like you
can only have four in the party so
just pick your four favorite characters
right well this one it was like you only
have these guys and they were [ __ ] and
annoying characters
yeah so it was like what am i supposed
to [ __ ] do this game sucks oh that's
not a good job
and then like one of the main enemies
just a snake coiled in like a [ __ ] and
the whole joke was that it was a piece
of [ __ ] and i'm like
yeah that sounds hilarious it's a piece
of [ __ ]
it's a metaphor for the game
i'm still annoyed about it i completed
it and i loved playing it but i
literally only played it because
it was like i bought this game my mom
won't buy me another one so i have to
complete
i need to play this now i want you to
play just so you can like
how did you get that game again so what
it was is like you know i don't know if
your game source had this but in the uk
they had a
three for 20 pounds pre-owned games oh
yeah yeah
so i would basically just go to the
thing and buy three games that looked
okay
yeah yeah and then i would be forced to
play them most of the time they were all
like super easy and you had an absolute
gold like blue dragon
there was like there was like one of
each game and there's a whole [ __ ]
shelf of blue dragons just like take
them take them honestly like for free
it comes with a badge was it like a was
it like a well-received
game at all or like almost very mid-tier
like
like five out of ten six hours this was
my first time ever having to swap discs
to progress with the story and that [ __ ]
pissed me off